this idea of multi-hierarchical
competence architecture which is
incredible to think about so this
hierarchy that Evolution builds I don't
know who's responsible for this
I also see the incompetence of
bureaucracies of humans when they get
together
so how the hell does evolution build
this where
at every level only the best get to
stick around they somehow figure out how
to do their job without knowing the
bigger picture
yeah and then there's like the bosses
that do the bigger thing
somehow or that you can now abstract
away the small group of cells as a as an
organ or something and then that organ
does something bigger
in the context of the full body or
something like this
how is that built is there some
intuition you can kind of provide of how
that's constructed that that
hierarchical confidence architecture
I love that component it's just the word
confidence is pretty cool in this
context because everybody's good at
their job somehow yeah no it's really
key and the other nice thing about
competency is that so so my my central
belief in all of this is that
engineering is the right perspective on
all of this stuff because it gets you
away from uh subjective uh terms you
know people talk about sentience and
this and that those things very hard to
define or people argue about them
philosophically I think that engineering
terms like competency like um you know
pursuit of goals right all of these
things are uh are empirically incredibly
useful because you know it when you see
it and if it helps you build right if I
if I can pick the right level I say uh
this thing has I believe this is X level
of food like competency I think it's
like a thermostat or I think it's like a
a better thermostat or I think it's a
you know a a various other kinds of you
know there's many many different kinds
of complex systems if that helps me to
control and and predict and build such
system then that's all there is to say
there's no more philosophy to argue
about so so I like competency in that
way because you can quantify you could
you have to in fact you have to you have
to make a claim competent at what and
then or if I say if I tell you it has a
goal the question is what's the goal and
how do you know and I said well because
every time I deviated from this
particular State that's what it spends
energy to get back to that's the goal
and we can quantify and we can be
objective about it so so so the the when
we're not used to thinking about this I
I give a talk sometimes called why don't
robots get cancer right and the reason
robots don't get cancer is because
generally speaking with a few exceptions
are our architectures have been you've
got a bunch of dumb parts and you hope
that if you put them together the the
the the overlying machine will have some
intelligence and do something or other
right but the individual Parts don't
don't care they don't have an agenda
biology isn't like that every level has
an agenda and the final outcome is the
result of cooperation and competition
both within and across levels so for
example during embryogenesis your
tissues and organs are competing with
each other and it's actually a really
important part of development there's a
reason they compete with each other
they're not all just uh you know sort of
helping each other they're also
competing for for information for
metabolic for limited metabolic
constraints
but to get back to your your other point
which is you know which is which is the
seems like really efficient and good and
and so on compared to some of our human
efforts we also have to keep in mind
that what happens here is that each
level
bends the option space for the level
beneath so that your parts basically
they don't see the the the geometry so
so I'm using um and I think I I take
this this seriously uh terminology from
from like um from like relativity right
where the space is literally bent so the
option space is deformed by the higher
level so that the lower levels all they
really have to do is go down their
concentration gradient they don't have
to in fact they don't they can't know
what the big picture is but if you bend
the space just right if they do what
locally seems right they end up doing
your bidding they end up doing things
that are optimal in the in the higher
space conversely because the components
are good at getting their job done you
as the higher level don't need to to try
to compute all the low level controls
all you're doing is bending the space
you don't know or care how they're going
to do it give you a super simple example
in the um in the tadpole we found that
okay so so tadpoles need to become frogs
and to become to go from a tadpole head
to a frog head you have to rearrange the
face so the eyes have to move forward
the Jaws have to to come out the
nostrils move like everything moves it
used to be thought that because all
tadpoles look the same and all frogs
look the same if you just remember if
every piece just moves in the right
direction the right amount then you get
your you get your fraud right so we
decided to test we I had this hypothesis
that I thought I thought actually the
system is probably more intelligent than
that so what did we do we made what we
call Picasso tadpoles so these are so
everything is scrambled so the eyes are
on the back of the head their jaws are
off to the side everything is scrambled
well guess what they make they make
pretty normal frogs because all the
different things move around in novel
paths configurations until they get to
the correct froggy sort of frog face
configuration then they stop so so the
thing about that is now imagine
Evolution right so so you make some sort
of mutation and it does like every
mutation it does many things so so
something good comes of it but also it
moves your mouth off to the side right
now if if if there wasn't this
multi-scale competency you can see where
this is going if there wasn't this
multi-scale competency the organism
would be dead your Fitness is zero
because you can't eat and you would
never get to explore the other
beneficial consequences of that mutation
you'd have to wait until you find some
other way of doing it without moving
them out that's really hard so so the
fitness landscape would be incredibly
rugged Evolution would take forever the
reason it works one of the reasons it
works so well is because you do that no
worries the mouth will find its way
where where it belongs right so now you
get to explore so so what that means is
that all these mutations that otherwise
would be deleterious are now neutral
because the competency of the parts
make up for all kinds of things so all
the noise of development all the the
variability in the environment all these
things the companies do the parts makes
up for it so the so so that's all that's
all fantastic right that's all that's
all great the only other thing to
remember when we compare this to human
efforts is this every component has its
own goals in various spaces usually with
very little regard for the welfare of
the other levels so so as a simple
example you know
um you as a as a complex system
um you will go out and you will do you
know Jiu Jitsu or whatever you'll have
some code to go rock climbing and scrape
a bunch of cells off your hands and then
you're happy as a system right you come
back and you've you've accomplished some
goals and you're really happy those
cells are dead they're gone right did
you think about those cells not really
right you had some you had some bruising
out selfish SLB that's it and so and so
that's the thing to remember is that
um you know and we know this from from
history is that is that just being a
collective isn't enough because uh what
the goals of that Collective will be
relative to the welfare of the
individual Parts is a massively open
question justify the means I'm telling
you Stalin was on to something no so
that's the danger but we can exactly
that's the danger of uh
for us humans we have to construct
ethical systems
under which we don't take seriously the
full mechanism of biology and apply it
to the way the world functions which is
which is an interesting line we've drawn
the world that built us
is the one we reject in some sense when
we construct human societies the idea
that this country was founded on that
all men are created equal that's such a
fascinating idea it's like uh you're
fighting against
nature
and you're saying well there's something
bigger here than um yeah a hierarchical
competency architecture yeah uh and but
there's so many interesting things you
said so from an algorithmic perspective
the act of bending the option space
that's really that's really profound
because if you look at the way AI
systems are built today there's a big
system like I said with robots and as a
goal and he gets better and better at
optimizing that goal at accomplishing
that goal
but if biology built a hierarchical
system where everything is doing
computation
and everything is accomplishing the goal
not only that
it's kind of dumb
you know with the uh with the limited
with the bent option space is just doing
the thing that's the easiest thing for
you in some sense
and somehow that allows you to have
um Turtles on top of turtles literally
dump systems on top of dump systems that
as a whole create something incredibly
smart yeah I mean every system is has
some degree of intelligence in its own
problem domain so so cells will have
problems they're trying to solve in
physiological space and transcriptional
space and then I could give you some
some cool examples of that but the
collective is trying to solve problems
in anatomical space right and forming a
you know a creature and growing your
blood vessels and so on and then the
collect the the the the whole body is
solving yet other problems they may be
in Social space and linguistic space in
three-dimensional space and and who
knows you know the group might be
solving problems in in um you know I
don't know some sort of financial space
or something so one of the major
differences with with most
um uh with most AIS today is is a the
the kind of flatness of the architecture
but also of the fact that they're
constructed
from outside their their borders and
their you know so so if you're so to a
large extent and of course there are
counter examples now but but to a large
extent our technology has been such that
you create a machine or a robot it knows
what its sensors are it knows what its
effectors are it knows the boundary
between it and the outside world all
this is given from the outside
biology constructs this from scratch now
the best example of this that that
originally uh in in robotics was
actually Josh bongard's work in 2006
where he made these these robots that
did not know their shape to start with
so like a baby these are floundered
around they made some hypotheses well I
did this and I moved in this way well
maybe I'm a whatever maybe I have wheels
or maybe I have six legs or whatever
right and they would make a model and
eventually they would crawl around so
that's I mean that's really good that's
part of the autopoiesis boy we can go a
step further and some people are doing
this and then we're sort of working on
some of this too is this idea that let's
even go back further you don't even know
what sensors you have you don't know
where you end and the outside world
begins all you have is is certain things
like active inference meaning you're
trying to minimize surprise right you
have some metabolic constraints you
don't have all the energy you need you
don't have all the time in the world to
to think about everything you want to
think about so that means that you can't
afford to be a micro
um reductionist you know all this data
coming in you have to coarse grain it
and say I'm going to take all this stuff
and I'm going to call that a cat I'm
gonna take all this I'm going to call
that the edge of the table I don't want
to follow off of and I don't want to
know anything about the microstates what
I want to know is what is the optimal
way to cut up my world and by the way
this thing over here that's me and the
reason that's me is because I have more
control over this than I have over any
of this other stuff and so now you can
begin to write so that's
self-construction that that figuring out
making models of the outside world and
then turning that inwards and starting
to make a model of yourself right which
immediately starts to get into issues of
agency and control because
in order to if if you are under
metabolic constraints meaning you don't
have the energy right that all the
energy in the world you have to be
efficient that immediately forces you to
start telling stories about coarse
grained agents that do things right you
don't have the energy to like laplace's
demon you know calculate every every
possible uh State that's going to happen
you have to you have to coarse grain and
you have to say that is the kind of
creature that does things either things
that I avoid or things that I will go
towards as a mate or food or whatever
it's going to be and so right at the
base of uh simple very simple organisms
starting to make
models of Agents doing things that is
the origin of uh models of of Free Will
basically right because you see the
world around you as having agency and
then you turn that on yourself and you
say wait I have agency too I can I do
things right and and then you make
decisions about what you're going to do
so all of this one one model is to view
all of those kinds of things as
being driven by that early need to
determine what you are and to do so and
to then take actions in the most
energetically efficient space possible
right so free will emerges when you try
to simplify tell a nice narrative about
your environment I think that's very
possible yeah